je me sens
seul
elle s'appelle élise à elle a 18 ans et
elle a décidé après le bac de s'accorder
un break de partir seul de quitter sa
famille et ses amis pendant trois mois
pour se sentir utile se faire sa propre
expérience s'ouvrir l'esprit
elle a décidé de s'engager sur un tout
nouveau projet
enfin des reins très la vie des études
j'ai pas ce qu'il faut faire un voyage
pour savoir vraiment où elles sont mais
c'est pas une année perdue si elle est
utilisée
si on fait quelque chose nos avions
rencontré elisa lorsqu'elle cherchait
une idée sur internet
elle tape aide humanitaire pour
étudiants un organisme propose des
chantiers écologique pour jeunes
on appelle cela la parenthèse utile un
concept anglo saxon qui débarque en
france
devenir parent thésards c'est
interrompre ses études pour partir à
l'étranger quelques mois et s'engager en
tant que bénévole pour aider un pays
alors direction la thaïlande
alors que les fêtes
elle atterrit là elisa sur les plages
d'alang dans le parc national de copies
un archipel paradisiaque au sud-est de
phuket une région dévastée par le
tsunami en 2004
depuis tous se reconstruit mais beaucoup
trop vite et parfois empire pour
l'exploitation du tourisme une mission
écologique s'est mise en place pour
limiter les dégâts sur la côte et isa
rejoindre d'autres jeunes venus comme
elle apporter ma forte et se faire une
expérience dans l'éco volontariat
ici les journées sont consacrées au
travail pour préserver deux écosystème
particulièrement menacé les récifs
coralliens et les forêts de mangroves se
comprend rien
et partout
première journée pour isa et premières
découvertes sur le paradis à sauvegarder
et ghana
qui plaisent unis
[Musique]
si je fais se poser ce voyage c'est pour
retrouvez j'avais besoin d'eux
de me sentir utile en fait j'avais
besoin de dialoguer avec des gens qui
m'étaient inconnues de partir dans des
paysages que je connaissais pas du tout
de savoir que j'apprenais cher qu'une
chose commune
ils sont une vingtaine comme elisa à
être des étudiants sur six venus du
monde entier se frotter à l'écologie et
c'est un plus une immersion
internationale avec américains italiens
belges et surtout beaucoup de danois
canton et scandinaves il est bien vue
d'inscrire sur son cv la ligne bénévolat
à l'étranger je fais deux ans de break
dont une amie où j'ai gagné de l'argent
pour pouvoir faire ce projet d'éco
volontariat alors les rencontres que tu
fais tu t'en enrichi je pense que j'ai
beaucoup changé depuis que je voyage et
je serai prêt à reprendre correctement
mes études parce que si on étudie en
suivant une route toute tracée je pense
qu'on s'ennuie très vite
personne ne sait vraiment ce qu'il veut
faire plus tard donc c'est très bien de
faire un break sur les îles du parc
national de copies pis il y a cinq ans
rien et est exploité ici depuis le
paradis côtoient l'enfer du tourisme de
masse
le monde sous-marin souffre de
l'invasion humaine c'est sous l'eau que
les volontaires doivent effectuer leur
travail
certains ont déjà le niveau en plongée
sous marine mais d'autres ont tout à
apprendre comme elisa venu ici pour
tenter l'expérience de la nouveauté et
se jeter à l'eau
[Musique]
deux premières impressions et sensations
l'impression d'être en apesanteur dans
les sondages mais on pense à rien le
temps postale
par contre j'ai été impressionné par
problème des décors qui sont
en train de disparaître parce que la
plupart des coraux seulement il n'ya
presque plus de couleurs ses grilles
c'est ce qu'on appelle le corail blanchi
plus rien ne pousse plus rien nos vies
c'est dû au réchauffement climatique et
à la pollution environnante
et si on allait y sous l'eau c'est
plutôt alarmant
[Musique]
ce qui dirige la mission écologique en
sont conscients marie elle est diplômée
en biologie marine
passionné c'est elle qui dirige le
projet d'éco volontariat
comme les gens construit sans prendre de
précaution énormément sur la côte
après tout la les sols en fait surtout
ici et puis arrive sur frei se trouve
dans la mer et il arrive sur les récits
voit on voit les particules qui se
dépose sur les coraux et dans l'eau moi
aussi
ça fait comme un espèce de nuages de
poussière là si ça continue comme ça moi
je pense
elle a eu le temps de se forger le
caractère mari elle vit en thaïlande
depuis trois ans et aime faire passer le
message auprès des volontaires
le parc national c'est ce qu'on appelle
un papier en fait
qui délimitent la zone du parc national
mais il n'y a pas grand chose de fait
pour
protéger des sites
la pêche est essentielle réglementé mais
là ils sont
un beau milieu du parc national
s'il est trop abîmé pour le réparer
miles
j'aime par-dessus bord quoi c
pose pas la question de savoir est ce
que
quel point qu'alain pas que ça va former
dans 5 x 15
la dernière fois qu'on est venus ici on
a repéré majeur filet alors ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui c'est qu'on va aller
ramasser en vérifiant bien qu'il n'ya
pas d'animal vivant à l'intérieur
si vous en trouvez eh bien vous les
libérer fruit des maps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
obama
à
[Musique]
le voilà le chantier écologique sous
l'eau pour jeunesse volontaires aux
corvées outings
je pense que je serais venu en thaïlande
pour 15 jours et peut-être plonger avec
un centre de plongée je me serais pas
rendu compte de la même chose ça permet
d'avoir une opinion et puis d'avoir
différents points de vue et je pense que
ça peut pas laisser indifférente d'avoir
des expériences comme ça ça peut pas
nous passer par dessus la tête et lisa
va apprendre à planter semer faire
pousser le corps à y contribuer à la
surveillance des récifs avec les
biologistes marins chaque jour elle aura
un travail différent pour soigner
l'océan
pour tous les jeunes venus là ce n'est
pas dérisoire
kevin lui en est convaincu il vient de
l'île et pour valider son diplôme
d'école d'ingénieur il doit faire un
stage à l'étranger pendant deux mois la
parenthèse utile le concept il y a tout
de suite adhéré en parle aux gens qu'ils
connaissent pas vraiment ils m'ont alors
dit je pars demande island as tu pars en
vacances supérieur non je vais
travailler plus de moi
nettoyer les fonds marins etc
je vais faire une bonne action je vais
pas en vacances on va pas sauver la
planète aujourd'hui je veux dire si on
se dit ok font rien donc nous on ne fait
rien
personne ne fera jamais rien donc faut
bien quelqu'un de face et en rentrant en
france je parlais de ce projet une
personne qui lui même va peut-être en
parle à une autre qui viendra peut-être
ans island et il jettera peut-être plus
à mégots par dessus bord et voilà ça
c'est toujours important
oui
quand j'ai commencé mes études et pas
tellement de programmes qui étaient
disposition un programme sur
l'environnement mais maintenant on en
voit de plus en plus quand ils repartent
quand ils auront appris plein de choses
puis quand tu reçois un email
un an plus tard d'un bénévole qui dit
bon bah ça y est de là je commence les
cours et puis je vais faire je vais
devenir biologiste marin et j'espère
faire une carrière dans le même domaine
va ce serait très très plaisir
un jour ou l'autre on a tous une bonne
raison d'aller voir ailleurs et elisa si
elle est parti c'est parce qu'elle avait
besoin de changer tout son monde
la jeune fille traîne dans ses bagages
une histoire tragique qui l'empêchent
d'avancer
le déclic pour moi qui m'a fait vraiment
partir cet été où j'ai eu un grave
accident de voiture au portugal
et
et non du coup
ma meilleure amie décédée dans
l'accident moi j'ai juste la clavicule
cassé deux côtes cassées
c'est quelque chose qui m'arrive équipe
a complètement bouleversé et qui m'a
complètement changé et donc du coup
maintenant en m'éloignant de tout ça et
de l'atmosphère dans laquelle j'étais
j'arrive à ne connaître à nouveau et
hilla a vu son ami mourir à ses côtés à
partir de là que faire sinon tout tenté
pour se reconstruire
ouais
avec sa petite caméra elle s'accroche à
de nouveaux souvenirs
quand on est sur une plage avec des
touristes de partout je m'attendais pas
de thaïlande tout gâcher
vision des patients dans les poubelles
de partout y compris à des déchets plein
air donc aujourd'hui boulot c'est de
nettoyer la plage ça va gagner ouais
voilà la relation maritale
récupérer
le v twin l'intégration groupe
maintenant ça y est
je me suis fait plein d'amis c'est vrai
qu'il ya des moments où ça doit
forcément facile de s'intégrer à un
groupe c'est pas forcément facile de
parler anglais
valence tous les jours se fondre dans le
décor un peu plus chaque jour pour mieux
s'imprégner et pour quelques graines
ramasser avec des écoliers thaïlandais
continue à prendre la mesure de
l'essentiel sur soi et sur les autres
gildas il fait partie de l'organisation
en thaïlande
75% des mangroves ont déjà disparu alors
il continue la leçon dégrade la et
pousse fatale à fleurs tu as la graine
de dents qui va germer et ça c'est déjà
une graine germée donc c'est déjà une
plante presque adulte et quand elle se
plante comme ça elles vont prendre ainsi
une fois qu'ils ont pris racine
elle se développe super vite en arbre et
développe des racines comme ça se
développe super vite en arbre c'est
vachement résistant aux vagues de
tsunami par exemple donc éventuellement
ici s'il y avait un ou une ami qui
passait ça casserait les tuera les
quelques dizaines de premiers mètres
mais après après ça ça va aller plus
loin si tu as un village derrière il
sera épargné
alors que la cites à une plage et que
t'as rien ça balaye tout et ça va allez
y les gens les voitures les maisons et
tout est cassé
me
moi j'en peux plus il fait trop chaud
mais ça va ça me plaît mon dieu
20h se réorienter les membres c'est
certain que la parenthèse utile et le
voyage devrait se développer en france
ça nous donne une expérience incroyable
et et on peut pas se permettre d'étudier
certaines choses en restant chez soi et
en essayant de pas avoir à côté et même
si c'est pas on n'est pas forcément de
traverse et bouge mais comme je suis en
train de le faire mais rien de
s'immerger dans une autre culture
il faut faire
je roule autres quoi parce que parce que
ça apporte réellement quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
dans les écoles ces ateliers pour
échange sur l'écologie les plus à l'aise
ils vont de bon coeur et se lance même
dans des exposés digne de futurs chefs
d'entreprise voilà parfois arrive un
homme très riche il veut acheter cette
mangrove parce que ce n'est pas cher
donc voilà ce qu'il fait c'est qui
lâchait de la forêt à quoi tous les
arbres
[Applaudissements]
mon nom et klaus vient du danemark
c'est tout au nord et il fait très froid
j'ai envie de faire plusieurs choses
mais oui tu te dis et je pense que je
veux enseigner le trot contact avec des
enfants et enseigner c'est mieux que de
juste y penser il ya des gens qui font
du volontariat en afrique par exemple
moi je leur ferai c'est sur un but de le
guen j'ai tellement appris dans l'équipe
il ya poncho si elle est thaïlandaise et
ancienne monitrice de plongée
c'est le tsunami qui lui a fait changer
radicalement de vie elle a appelé
l'organisme d'écovolontariat et a décidé
d'aider son pays à des choses en
thaïlande et certains endroits où besoin
dead
depuis dix ans les choses changent
beaucoup trop road qui ont construit des
routes de plus en plus grande de plus en
plus d'immeubles
il ya beaucoup de touristes je suis
contente qu'il y ait des gens qui
viennent dans mon pays à pouvoir comme
il est beau mais en même temps oui il
faut qu'on s'entraide que cela rendrait
les choses meilleures
evènement pénis bêta
[Musique]
les grands
avec sa d'aller à la rencontre des gens
ça me permet de voir que d'autres
personnes des choses difficiles et qui
s'en sortent le monde ne s'arrête pas
quand c'est pas parce qu'on est mal que
ça s'arrête et on peut pas se permettre
d'attendre d'être mal quand il faut
qu'on avance et quand on rencontre des
gens
pertinemment que
et chacun son propre vie chacun ses
propres expériences et que si on les
partage pas ses céramiques
nous
elle
chante
magnifique là
je peux très bien après les trois mois
sont vite passés un dernier moment
encore avant de rentrer elisa retrouve
mehdi c'est la nounou bienveillante des
volontaires et avec elisa il a créé des
liens particuliers moi je suis retraité
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas grand-chose à
faire alors j'aime bien m'occuper des
volontaires
les touristes ils viennent ils regardent
c'est tout ils ne comprennent pas
forcément notre quotidien que les
volontaires avec tout ce qu'ils font eh
bien ils sont proches de nous et il
cerne j'ai l'impression que mieux notre
façon de vivre
mehdi veut montrer une dernière chose et
lisa pourtant il ne connaît rien de son
histoire mais dit ne sais pas quel isa
promène avec elle le souvenir d'une amie
disparue et sans le savoir il va lui
apporter la dernière étincelle qui est
bloquée et les hasselt opère retire ta
chance et tu oses tu fais exactement
comme moi
c'est à peu près ce que tu faisais je
viens faisait nos francs enfin je leur
donnais annoncé je comprends
d'accord il veut qu'on fait ça tu vois
ils ont mis deux lola dans les petites
et qu elles toutes les bonnes choses que
tu fais en ce moment tout ce que tu as
de positif en toi et bien c'est chose ah
tu peux les envoyer par la pensée à
quelqu'un que tu aimes vraiment très
fort ou quelqu'un que tu respecte
beaucoup et qui serait partie là où elle
serait décédée tu vois ce que je veux
dire en fait on utilise loup comme un
médium pour transmettre tout ça
attaquants arrivent à être coriace orale
sous du scud
il n'y en somme
tbwa
parce que
oui je me sens heureuse en fait je me
sens soulagé de tout l'impression
j'avais adorable tous les jours à
grenoble j'étais obligé d'y penser en
fait et en arrivant aussi
je me sens heureuse pour de bon quand
j'ai l'impression je suis soulagé et que
je peux enfin avancer j'ai j'ai
l'impression d'avoir fermer un chapitre
mais que l'aja une petite pause que je
qui va me permettre d'avancer et en
arrivant en france à nouveau je pourrais
écrire un chapitre
[Musique]
moi
elisa ne rentrera pas tout de suite en
france elle décide de continuer
l'expérience du volontariat
elle part au cambodge apporter son aide
dans un orphelinat quelques mois encore
il voudrait
m
oh